She may just be
20 years old,
but Isabela Merced
is already a huge star,
and her career
is just getting started.
To celebrate her star turn
in Netflix's Sweet Girl,
let's take a look at
the roles that got her here,
in her Road to Netflix...
The acting bug hit Isabela
from a young age,
making her Broadway debut
at just 10 years old
in a production of Evita,
alongside Ricky Martin.
Her TV acting career began
picking up steam in 2013,
when she had
a recurring role
in NBC's family sitcom,
Growing Up Fisher.
Your dad didn't tell you?
My mum's out of town
for work
so I'm going to Catalina
with you guys.
And in 2014, she had
a recurring voice role
on Dora and Friends:
Into the City!
A sequel to the original
children's series.
I'm Kate and these are
my friends, Dora and Pablo.
But her breakthrough role
came in 2014,
on Nickelodeon's 100 Things
to Do Before High School,
where she played
middle schooler CJ Martin,
who, along with
her two best friends,
makes a bucket list
filled with things
to accomplish
before high school.
I just want to say,
I am not proud
of what I'm about to do.
She also appeared in other
Nickelodeon productions,
including 2015's
Splitting Adam
and 2016's Legends
of the Hidden Temple.
This is a restricted area,
I'm putting my foot down.
Also that year, she played
the super-smart president
of a middle school AV club,
Gene, in Middle School:
The Worst Years of My Life,
an adaptation of the 2011
novel of the same name.
I just love that someone has
the guts
to take on
the establishment.
By 2017, Isabela was
on the big screen
in the fifth instalment
of the Transformers
film series,
alongside Mark Wahlberg
and fellow Netflix alum,
Laura Haddock.
Her character,
Izabella with a Z,
is a young orphaned
scavenger on Earth,
whose only companions
are two autobots.
I want to stay
and I want to fight them.
Transformers director,
Michael Bay, gave her
the opportunity to add a few
Spanish words to her part,
after hearing her
speak Spanish
with her mother on set.
That year was
definitely busy for her.
She also appeared
in the hugely popular
Kingdom Hearts series,
voicing Ava
in the English dub.
And what's written
in the book...
all of it will happen.
2018's
Sicario: Day of the Soldado
brought a meteor role
and change in genre
to Isabela's resume,
when she played the daughter
of a drug kingpin
in the action crime sequel.
I know who you are.
You're the attorney
whose family they killed.
Her character, Isabel,
is captured by a CIA team
aiming to start a war
between drug cartels
on the US/Mexico border.
She was reunited
with Mark Wahlberg
in 2018's Instant Family,
a comedy drama
where a couple decide
to adopt three siblings.
Isabela played 15-year-old
Izzy, the eldest sibling,
who is initially
not on board
with the whole
adoption thing.
Just let me talk to her,
please,
and then we can figure
something out and...
-Honey…
-...she can take me home.
Remember how
Isabela had a voice role
in the Dora series?
Well, she stepped it up
in 2019 by taking on
the lead role
in the live action version,
Dora and the Lost City
of Gold,
playing a grown-up version
of the iconic
children's character.
The movie sees Dora
head to high school,
a far cry
from her explorer roots.
That is until she
and her friends are captured
by mercenaries trying
to steal treasures in Peru.
Oh, and there's another
Mark Wahlberg
connection here.
His nephew Jeff Wahlberg
play Diego in the film.
Cousin Diego!
You're so skinny and tall!
You are way more energetic
than I remember.
Her first appearance
on a Netflix Original
also came that year
in the Christmas romcom,
Let It Snow.
Snow hides a lot
It's like the space
of weather.
You can do a lot worse
than this place, trust me.
Isabela's character Julie
is a girl
who has a scholarship
to Columbia,
but feels like
she can't leave her mother,
who is ill.
She and a rising pop star
strike up a
will they-won't they romance
when they meet on a train
which get stopped
by snowed over tracks.
That brings us to 2021,
when she made
a return to voice acting,
in Dreamworks Animation's
Spirit Untamed.
I'm going to call you
Spirit.
And of course she stars
alongside Jason Momoa
in Netflix's Sweet Girl.
This is a tale of a man
and his daughter
versus some shady
pharmaceutical companies.
Ray, played by Jason,
is devastated
when his wife dies
of terminal cancer,
shortly after
a life-saving drug
is pulled from the market.
But his quest for revenge
on the company responsible
lands him and his daughter,
played by Isabela,
in a whole load of trouble.
Dad!
And Isabela's Rachel
isn't taking any
of this lying down.
I know you're fighting
for us.
But this is my fight too.
She joins her father
in the fight for justice.
And what happens next?
Well, you'll have to catch
Sweet Girl,
now streaming on Netflix.
And for more on your
favourite Netflix stars,
make sure you subscribe
to the channel.